ea capacidade de buscá lo criando uma
sociedade justa e auto sustentável
eu mudei muitas coisas o que der
botafogo lagoa ou já com uma coisa e
tentei dormir assim e eu podia tá morto
é o preso
vamos ver muita coisa
os amigos aqui o fernando se refere na
época desse depoimento dois estavam
presos e um tinha sido executado
eu tô aqui pra falar de iniciativa
social e transformação social
eu fundei a 13 anos atrás o projeto
wimbelemdon que é um projeto social que
ensina tênis e complementação escolar a
crianças e adolescentes de belém novo um
bairro na zona sul de porto alegre
o nome ele é uma brincadeira com o nome
do bairro óbvio e uma homenagem ao
torneio de tênis mais tradicional do
mundo
a gente começou como quase toda a
iniciativa social com o coração com
muita boa vontade e com uma pitadinha de
criatividade
toda vez que é que o que eu ia do meu
escritório em beleza da minha casa nem
de novo no meu escritório no centro da
cidade
eu passava na frente uma casa abandonada
e eu ficava pensando quanta coisa legal
daria para fazer um espaço desse assim
que apareceu uma placa de aluga se eu
corri primeiro coisa que eu fiz foi
correr para fazer um contrato de longo
prazo como fotógrafo não tinha sequer a
não tinha a mínima idéia do por onde
começar o que eu poderia fazer eu só
tinha esse nome legal ea boa vontade é
isso foi em outubro foi isso foi em
outubro de 2000
o projeto começou em março de 2003 com
40 crianças dobrou em seguida para 80 e
hoje a gente atende mais de 100 crianças
e adolescentes com aulas diárias de
tênis e oficinas semanais obrigatórias
de matemática português
psicologia e oficina de cinema e vídeo
desde o início a gente fazia a mesma
pergunta para todas as crianças que
entravam projeto
qual é o seu sonho eu não preciso nem um
matemático para fazer uma grave
constatação eles não tinham nem idéia do
que eles queriam ser o que eles queriam
pro seu futuro
as camadas menos favorecidas da nossa
sociedade
elas vão perdendo essa capacidade de
sonhar só que bem diferente do que
acontecia há muito tempo atrás hoje
quase todas as casas têm uma televisão
então como não ver aqueles comerciais
maravilhosos fantástica de que tem um
carrão ontem aquele par de tênis é um
sinônimo de felicidade né
é exatamente aí que que as pessoas ficam
com aquele desejo que é super forte
buzinando naquela necessidade
aquela falsa necessidade de ter aquele
produto aquela felicidade tem criança
que mata por um par de tênis
exatamente aí que entra um dos papéis
fundamentais do esporte que saber perder
que a tolerá a frustração seja que devem
estar se perguntando tamasy porque o
tênis eu vou pegar emprestado a frase do
norte americano arthur ash que foi o
primeiro tenista negro a ganhar um
torneio de grand slam
ele foi um lutador contra o racismo e
contra a pobreza no mundo
o tênis a prática do tênis ajuda as
crianças a desenvolver a ética do
trabalho disciplina lidar com erros e
resolver problemas responsabilizar se
por suas ações controlar suas emoções
diante de dificuldades em lidar com o
stress pressão e tensão tomar decisões
através do planejamento dos melhores
golpes estratégias desenvolver rituais
efetivos de desempenho desenvolver o
espírito esportivo e habilidades sociais
ganhar dignamente e perder com honra e
desenvolver o espírito de equipe e de
comunicação
nestes mais de dez anos de atividade
nós comprovamos na prática
o que é que todas as frases do ator
ashton se o não e ficam gravadas
internamente nas nossas crianças é como
qualquer esporte individual e
principalmente tênis ele faz com que as
crianças descubram que elas podem
sozinhas vencer obstáculos e vencer o
jogo né que elas criam a desenvolvem
habilidades e atitudes positivas que
permite que elas possam se inserir na
sociedade futuro no futuro
então voltando à nossa visão lá no
início é que todas as crianças têm um
sonho ea capacidade de buscá lo criando
uma sociedade justa e auto sustentável
ea nossa missão disse que através do
ensino do tênis integrado à leitura ea
complementação escolar facilitar o
desenvolvimento de habilidades e
atitudes em crianças em situação de
risco social que lhes permitam
participar ativamente da sociedade
brasileira
a gente não inventou absolutamente nada
a gente só usa essa receita que mistura
esporte lazer com um aprendizado e
complementação escolar e como eu tinha
dito antes né com uma pitada com um
pouquinho de criatividade bom há quatro
anos nós inventamos as olimpíadas de
verão
eram jogos e brincadeiras por equipe
valendo ponto com a presença facultativa
os beneficiários a campanha e tarde eles
se reuniam todas as manhãs em função do
menor calor nessa temperatura mais amena
as equipes envolviam as crianças de 6 a
18 anos forçando a integração à
comunicação a paciência a tolerância o
sucesso desse evento oficializou desde
então as olimpíadas de verão e de
inverno e os dez melhores eles
participavam de uma coisa quem chamou de
um dia perfeito
eles passaram o dia no clube com direito
a almoço a piscina futebol e é óbvio que
muito tênis não podia deixar de ser
sempre nem sempre acontece nas férias
escolares foi um pouco polêmico mas foi
muito positivo quando a gente introduziu
a competição a ida à
torneios incrível que mesmo perdendo nas
primeiras rodadas nos lá nos primeiros
torneios as crianças voltavam uma
alegria quanta gente era ela como assim
eles voltavam bem mais motivados para os
nossos treinos e para as nossas oficinas
ela como se eles tivessem tido um clique
e descoberto que dali pra frente só
dependeria absolutamente deles que eles
poderiam se dedicar mais se concentrar
mais e que eles poderiam ganhar o jogo e
esse jogo senhores e senhoras
evidentemente não obrigatoriamente uma
partida de tênis é essa mudança de
atitude é impressionante
a partir daí a gente tem sido convidado
para ir a custo zero em vários torneios
de tênis uma outra coisa legal é que
eles são a nossa avaliação eles são
mensalmente avaliados em todas as
oficinas por comportamento presença e
comprometimento não são provas
essa avaliação juntamente com a com o
desempenho escolar é que é decisiva para
saber quem vai nos passeios e quem vai
nos torneios
bom parece que tudo é perfeito é que
tudo é maravilhoso mas ele evidentemente
a gente teve muitas dificuldades nesse
nosso caminho e ainda temos ainda hoje
por exemplo a devida assim algumas
minorias oportunistas e que transitam
pelo terceiro setor
a desconfiança existe com as ongs e ela
é grande a gente encarou esse essa
dificuldade adotando todos os princípios
da boa gestão e da transparência tendo
inclusive um capítulo inteiro do nosso
case ilustrado um livro chamado ong
transparência como fator crítico de
sucesso que fala da o projeto piloto do
banco interamericano de desenvolvimento
bid
desenvolveu juntamente com a ong
parceiros voluntários capacitando os 76
ongs no rio grande do sul
uma outra dificuldade foi o preconceito
eles não precisam de dinheiro só uma ong
rica estão sempre na mídia o meligeni
sempre ajuda
eles trabalham com o tênis é um esporte
de burguês né
com essas pérolas que a gente enfrenta
os leões
o einstein já dizia que é mais fácil
desintegrar o átomo do que o preconceito
e inclusão social como um esporte de
elite
desconstruindo quebra de paradigmas
a gente é teimoso nós estamos tentando e
superando isso todos os dias
o nosso bairro fica bem afastado do
centro do centro de porto alegre o que o
que as pessoas vão ter muito longe isso
dificulta muito convidar pessoas
empresários para visitar o trabalho que
a gente faz a gente sentiu a necessidade
de criar um evento que reunisse ação
social gastronomia diversão e muito
tênis foi aí que surgiu o rolando arroz
ele é uma alusão ao charmoso torneio
francês de roland garros ele é um
torneio de 8 30 às 11 11 aluno do
projeto um tenista profissional e o
empresário jogam o torneio super
divertido
os alunos vão decidir definidos pelo
nosso ranking interno
os que não jogam são goleiros de todos
os outros participam da arroz olimpíadas
que é uma versão enxuta nas olimpíadas
de inverno e de verão
o auge das olimpíadas inclusive são as
mímicas onde os jogadores que não estão
na quadra tem que participar de uma das
equipes e representar com gestos alguma
palavra valendo ponto nas quatro edições
nós trouxemos vários tenistas
profissionais voluntários ovos com a
participar do do rolando arroz o ano
passado o gustavo guga kuerten nos deu a
honra da sua presença levando mais de
mil pessoas ao nosso evento onde
servimos mais de 600 posições de risotos
dezenas de quilos de bolinho de arroz
que estavam maravilhosos e todos
elaborados por 11 chefes todas
voluntárias é nós acreditamos que os
nossos melhores meios de verificação do
impacto positivo e dos resultados
obtidos nessa nossa caminhada é a
verificação e acompanhamento
o dos nossos alunos e os alunos agora
que eu tenho a oportunidade e também de
melhorar o meu futuro aprendendo tênis
tendo aulas de inglês leitura é uma
grande chance para a gente ter um futuro
melhor
o léo aí tinha 13 anos esse depoimento
falou um pouquinho mais famosas não eu
acho que era uma pessoa que existia
muito fácil das coisas
aquele projeto aprendi a te persistência
muita resistência principalmente diante
jogo é difícil dizer se de um ponto
e esse é o resto do muito a minha vida
pessoal não tivessem tempo correto nem
sei como o bahia onde como seria conhece
os jogadores que passaram pelas mesmas
coisas que a gente já morava na favela
se hoje são grandes jogadores
acho que é a história que mais o marcou
assim foi do feijão quando ele veio aqui
e ponto para 9
fiquei muito surpresa que a ouvi ele
falar me deu mais vontade de continuar
no projeto prefeitura acredita que a
gente teria muitas chances
leonardo baltazar hoje com 21 anos está
fazendo o trabalho de conclusão no
matemática na universidade federal do
rio grande do sul passou também esse ano
no vestibular de ciências atuariais e
não satisfeito com a falta de tempo e
ainda bateu na nossa porta e um
voluntário da oficina de de matemática
[Música]
todo dia tem um motivo que levou
vantagem por já saber que você feliz
aqui do essa janela também diz ela está
no projeto entrou no projeto com nove
anos de idade e ela hoje tem 18 é o
último ano no projeto em 2011 ela
participou de três torneios foi campeã
em 1 em 2012 foram 43 títulos e este ano
já ganhou três torneios isso a nossa a
gente o nosso objetivo não é formar um
grande tenista e sim um grande cidadão
todos sabem lá eternamente que ela só
foi nesse torneio todos porque ela
estava bem em todas as nossas oficinas e
evidentemente um colégio em março a
dialética participou de 11 um torneio
internacional de tênis onde ela perdeu
na última rodada do qualifying é esse
jogo durou mais quase três horas e na
partida o terceiro e último set ela
começou a ter cãibras generalizadas
ela lutou muito perdeu só que ela perdeu
com a cabeça erguida e ela foi
compensada ela ganhou um patrocínio de
uma grande marca de raquetes e ela
também ganhou uma bolsa de 100% para em
2015 estudar em alguma universidade
americana e melhor né fazendo o que ela
mais gosta que é jogando tênis
ela sabe que ela tem maior desafio da
vida dela ela tem que continuar indo bem
na escola com as notas ela tem que
continuar bem nas oficinas ela tem que
continuar também treinando e jogando bem
para poder representar uma universidade
mas enfim a gente sabe que não vai ser
fácil principalmente que ela tem o ano o
ano que vem o final 2014 ela tem que
passar em dois testes como se fossem
vestibulares
o troféu e oeste ambos em inglês
enfim é um belo desafio a gente está
torcendo por ela mas para nós não
importa já é uma grande campeã
gente isso que eu acabei de mostrar aqui
chama-se transformação social
parece que acreditamos como uma verdade
absoluta que ou fazemos o bem para nós
mesmos e para a nossa família ou fazemos
o bem para o mundo para os outros que a
gente precisa
a optar por um outro caminho se uma
grande besteira na verdade deve ter sido
inventada por um grande um preguiçoso
que não deve estar sentado aqui né
transformação social faz o bem
gera bem estar não só nas outras pessoas
testemunhar transformação social
comparticipa de transformação social ou
até mesmo promover a transformação
social que faz sim sentir bem mas de
maneira nenhuma tem que ser especial o
herói pra começar a gerar o bem estar
vocês acreditam em papai noel em batman
e mulher maravilha
vocês vão ficar por exemplo esperando
que o que o super homem venha a resolver
todos os problemas na nossa vida
resolver salvar o nosso planeta
é claro que existirão vários seres
especiais que transformaram muitos
fizeram grandes transformações jesus
cristo muda uma garrafa grande né e
tantos outros mas eu insisto que
qualquer ser humano pode começar uma
iniciativa social é fácil todos podem
basta dar um passo de cada vez a gente
tem que a gente pode chegar lá
comece por exemplo trocando o não pelo
porque não usa esse mantra várias vezes
no seu dia para dar o primeiro passo é
fácil um monge tibetano gum poupa ele
disse lá no século 10
quanto mais ampliamos nosso foco para
incluir os interesses de outros ao lado
dos nossos mais fortes construímos os
alicerces da nossa própria felicidade
gente nunca é tarde pra ser feliz nunca
é tarde para começar a fazer o bem é só
começar porque não muito obrigado
[Aplausos]